اليوم ال8 للمعارك المتواصله في قطاع غزه
الاعنف لا يزال ففق ما تقوله الخرائط
وتقوله كتابه القسام والجيش الاسرائيلي لا
يزال التركيز في المناطق الشماليه في
المنطقه الوسطى وفي المنطقه الجنوبيه من
خان يونس الى البريج ومحيطها في الشمال من
دير البلح والمنطقه الشماليه مدينه غزه
ومحيطها اذا ما دخلنا مباشره الى المنطقه
الجنوبيه تقول يقول الجيش الاسرائيلي انه
بدا التركيز على المنطقه الجنوبيه الشرقيه
من مدينه خان يونس يضغط من منطقه خزاعه
كما قال الجيش الاسرائيلي بان فلسطينيين
الذين دخلوا يوم السابع من اكتوبر دخلوا
منطقه خزاعه المنطقه الحدوديه على السياج
الفاصل بين اسرائيل وقطاع غزه كما نشاهد
على الخريطه هذا الضغط من منطقه خزاعه
يوافقه او يتزامن معه ضغط من المنطقه
الشرقيه منطقه عبسان وبنسي المنطقه
الشماليه الشرقيه ومن الجهه الشماليه
بطبيعه الحال وصولا الى المنطقه الش
الشماليه الغربيه كما نشاهد على الخريطه
من مدينه حمد والمواصله الان او التركيز
على مدينه خانيونس يسع الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي لدخول مدينه خانيونس لانه
يعتبرها مركز عمليات كتاب القسام
والمقاومه الفلسطينيه حتى هذه اللحظه لم
تستطع اليات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الدخول
الى مدينه خان يونس والمنزل الذي تم
استهدافه ليحيى السنوار يقع في محيط مدينه
غزه كما ذكر الجيش الاسرائيلي وليس منزله
او معقله الطبيعي المعتاد في مدينه خان
يونس اذا حتى هذه اللحظه مدينه خان يونس
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي عاجز عن الدخول اليها
لكنه يضغط بشكل كبير على اطراف مدينه خان
يونس ويقصف بطبيعه الحال احياء متفرقه من
مدينه خان يونس اذا حتى هذه اللحظه مدينه
خان يونس لم يتم الدخول اليها ولم يتم
التوغل داخل مدينه خان يونس رغم الضغط
الكبير الذي تشهده خان يونس كما يقول
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بدفع لواء جديد
للقتال في المنطقه الجنوبيه اذا ما ذهبنا
الى المنطقه ال الشماليه فنحن نتحدث عن
مجموعه من الاحداث المهمه التي وقعت في
المنطقه الشماليه في تل الزعتر في جبل
الريس في الشعب في التفاح في الدرج بهذه
الصوره التي نشاهدها على الخريطه في تل
الزعتر تم اسقاط مسيره مسيره التجسس
الاسرائيليه كما اعلنت كتائب القسام في
منطقه تكاد تكون مدمره بشكل كامل منطقه
بيت حنون والاطراف الشماليه لتل الزعتر
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي توغل الى هذه المناطق
ووصل الى هذه المناطق اثناء المع البريه
وبطبيعه الحال كان قد دمرها بشكل شبه كامل
اليوم تقول المقاومه الفلسطينيه انها
استطاعت اسقاط مسيره مسيره تجسس اسرائيليه
في هذه المنطقه الى الجنوب قليلا من هذه
المنطقه والى الشرق من مدينه جباليه نتحدث
عن جبل الريس والشعف والتفاح والدرج في في
التفاح والدرج قالت كتاب القسام انها دمرت
خلال الساعات 48 الماضيه 20 اليه عسكريه
اسرائيليه في هذه المنطقه الصغيره وان ان
هذا العدد يتراكم ليصل 72 اليه في هاتين
المنطقتين في حيي التفاح والدرج واحدهما
الاليات العسكريه المدمره و كانت كان مصدر
قيادي في كتائب القسام قال قبل قليل خلال
الساعات الماضيه بانه تم تدمير او تم
استهداف في كمين محكم شرق منطقه التفاح تم
استهداف ناقله جند اسرائيليه تم تدميرها
بشكل كامل وقتل عشر جنود اسرائيليين من
المسافه صفر في منطقه التفاح شرق حي
التفاح في هذه منطقه شمالي مدينه غزه هذا
بالاضافه كما ذكرنا الى
ال الكمائن المحكمه والاستهداف القويه كما
نشر كتاب القسام في مقاطع فيديو القتال
العنيف في هذه المناطق في منطقه جبل
الرييس والشعف بالاضافه الى التفاح والدرج
هذه المناطق لا تزال تشهد عمليات عسكريه
عنيفه من قبل كتائب القسام وهذا ايضا يتسق
مع الروايه الاسرائيليه اذ قال الناطق
باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي ان الجيش لا يزال
يعمل في منطقتي التفاح والدرج بشكل فعال
في المقابل تقول قت انها توجه ضربات عنيفه
ل جنود الاحتلال والياته في منطقتي التفاح
والدرج نبقى ان نذهب الى المنطقه الوسطى
من قطاع غزه منطقه دير البلح ومنطقه مخيم
البريج بدرجه اساسيه يتوغل الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي من المنطقه الشرقيه يحاصر
المنطقه الشماليه لذا المخيم المقاومه
الفلسطينيه اليوم قالت انها
فجرت حقل الغام في اليات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي التي تحاول التوغل في منطقه
مخيم البريج هذا المخيم الصغير في وسط
قطاع غزه الذي يدخل بقوه الى واجهه
الاحداث بعمليات المقاومه الفلسطينيه ضد
اليات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي التي تحاول
الدخول الى المنطقه الوسطى من جهه مخيم
البريج هذه بشكل عام صوره الاحداث وابرزها
في المناطق الشماليه الوسطى والجنوبيه في
اليوم ال84 للقتال المتواصل في قطاع غزه